Từ ở một cái vụ của mình kênh quay theo chú này
Nên thường là ít trẻ thông đường thảo để mà rùi hàng hợp xói đi tìm
Còn các cái vụ là mình cứu nè trẻ thông
Nhưng là cái hỏi ui, mình đã ăn ui, nó không trẻ lượng hình lạnh
Nó đang quay từ giông của mình ở một sòng hình quan sàng của quay sàng của họ
Mọi người có bò trẻ trẻ thông chè, nó chè mơ quan sàng của nó
Quay sàng của mình từ ở một khoảng gọi giống của mình không đi theo chí ông này ở nông, khoảng gọi giống
Dí khi các bạn có thể, cái em là cái gì vậy?
Anh em thấy không có đi đâu về biển á
Em đi nữa có em được đặt từ lắm một cái dúc của mình thì anh em đang là một cái mỏ sách quanh được đặt
Vúng không về không?
Vúng về không?
Đại cái nỗi mọi không thì em không?
Công gì để dúc không?